with the adage that you want to do
everything for real it means doing the
stunts for real Hunter
from the opening sequence it's all real
I don't know
Jenny and Chris both rules the challenge
into themselves it was never expected
for us to do our stunts it was always
offered if we wanted to try it I think
there's just so much Curiosity on my
part in Denise to try it that we we did
we did all of our own stunts we were
actually hanging on with one hand it was
terrifying we really needed to be in
good physical shape to be able to do
this movie I had blisters on my hands
from climbing that ladder we would be
climbing that tower for hours every day
up and down up and down you know you do
a take climbing up you gotta climb back
down to do another take to climb back up
they had to wrap our hands in CGI the
wraps out at certain points because our
hands were just getting so torn up from
climbing this thing so many times
on a certain shot where Grace grabs a
ladder and would rigged a camera to a
ladder and I really wanted that kind of
going over the edge of a roller coaster
feeling did all this stuff thinking I'm
actually using a double and Grace is
like can I just do it can I just like do
the fall are you sure and I think
because I was comfortable with it in
small bits when we got to the actual
main ladder drop moment I was really
excited because I thought
I can do this I've done the other things
I I can do this I want to do this
[Music]
capturing that keeping it all real is is
key
[Music]
audiences want the real deal
and for this movie
it lives or dies I'm capturing that
reality